I am thrilled to have sitting to my
right right here a two-time Academy
Award winner of whom I am a huge fan and
greatly appreciative of being here in
advance of hotel Artemis being in
theaters near you right tonight right
here on the Rich Eisen show Jodie Foster
good to see you good seat you bet before
we get into Hotel Artemis I do want to
get into the fact that I believe you are
a fantasy football player is that a true
story Jodie Foster I am I did not play
last year because of the president
administration was you know I had to be
on the top of that and you can't get all
those alerts all at once so just too
much for me too many badges on your
phone your phone I had to choose no I
think next year and I think this year
I'm going to choose fantasy for sure
well I mean it's an escape though right
I mean when you say call it a mistake
escape I would call it a you know a
hyper-focused art form interesting yeah
fantasy football is a hyper focus you're
gonna do it you want to win okay have
you have you been so fortunate to win a
fantasy league my second
who are you in a fantasy league with a
bunch of sixteen year olds yeah and I
have to say I do enjoy none of them will
trash talk with me because you know you
can do that thing where you sort of type
in like you're going down or right and
nobody will do that they're just very
polite 16 year olds fan is that now that
so what's your team name what was your
fantasy team name your I can't tell you
why not to kill you if I told you I
would love to know because that's most
of the fun that we thought that's most
of the fun it kind of is okay yeah so
but you finished in second I did come in
second do you recall who was on your on
your team well I
I got seriously burned by Todd Gurley it
was his first you know season with the
rounds like he just he disappointed me
yes pretty severely that was a bad year
to be holding Todd Gurley senior time
that now so lad two years ago would have
been the time to pay attention to
politics yeah and leave Todd Gurley
exactly
she would have been the time to have
todd gurley and leave politics you know
what I'm saying I know I feel like I'm
I'm I'm stating the obvious here so I
apologize okay so girly burned you in
that year okay
did you have a you a real football team
that you love yes okay I love the Green
Bay Packers how'd that come about Jodi
somebody gave me a cheesehead and it was
all over that's it yeah that's all it
took who was it was it De Niro friend of
mine who has like an in with them so
he's not just a cheese head but it was a
cheese head everything no there was like
a cheese mug and there was a cheese ring
and there was a cheese headband okay she
got into that and she's like dog dog
outfits mm-hmm have you ever been to
Lambeau Field have you ever been never
have it's unbelievable that's what I've
heard because it's you're just in there
it's a Midwest town and you're driving
down a road and there's a gas station
there's a Kmart there is the there is
the there is the Cathedral well a
football word Lombardi used to play I
can dream I can dream if I do well you
know if I do pretty well in fantasy
maybe like maybe you can you can i had
you know i decided i discovered Davante
Adams so cuz I had him the whole year so
my gosh they call him my man Devante
does he know that you know that maybe
he'll know it now okay have you ever met
Aaron Rodgers your Sanders I think the
two you just even though we've just
we've just chatted just briefly now I
think the two of you would hit it off
you think I do I absolutely do cuz I'm
sure he's seen all your films I know how
did shellac he's you know and he is also
interested in things other than football
okay he's one of those guys that will be
able to talk about anything good he's
that him so no I have a lot of opinions
how about Favre if you met far I've
never met far have you ever met a Green
Bay Packer I've never met agreement we
need to make these dreams come true okay
if that is exactly what you're looking
for yes Jodie Foster here on the Rich
Eisen show but we need your Dean Nelson
I can meet Jordy Nelson now that he's no
longer yes Jordy Nelson's just a hop
skip and a jump hop skip and jump up to
Oakland now interesting that there there
are some in Oakland in the black hole
the vaunted black hole all those fans
who do have a Hannibal Lecter type look
to them is that right I'm saying you
might go back down a little bit of
memory lane when you see some of these
folks out there okay they've got masks
okay I don't know what they're like you
know with a Chianti or anything like
that so I like it
so Hotel Artemis it's your first film in
five years correct as an actress your
first film where you are in front in
five years I should say that why did you
decide to do this film Jodie Foster you
know I just loved it I loved the script
and I loved the idea of creating a
character that felt like a
transformation for me and she's a seven
year old lady with you know fat pad and
gray hair and some yellow teeth and
money walk right and that was exciting
to me I mean it's it's kind of nice to
be at that point in your career where
you can say as an actor I only want to
do it because I love it and I just I
don't really have any other ambitions
beyond that so I may do it less
frequently the acting right when I do it
I think people know that it's gonna be
something that's sort of original and
off-the-wall right and it you know
seeing the film it is kind of a grim
view of what Los Angeles look like ten
years from now where somebody's fiction
is always a you know predestination of
where we're headed so it always knows
what their problems are now and ask that
question of where are we going and so
this film although it is a super
kick-ass sci fi you know fun film does
ask some questions about you know what
happens to healthcare when nobody can
afford it and you know what happens to
police brutality in Los Angeles and what
have what about the water crisis what
are we going to do when we run out of
water so it sort of posits that ten
years in the future yeah it does have
sort of a Blade Runner ish type feel to
it you know when you see that as well no
seriously I know well then there's some
fun in it and a lot less rain but it
seems to me in you're just taking a look
at your your filmography that you do
like the science fiction science fiction
genre I do I like thinking movies so
like movies that think a lot and but I
also like them to be entertaining as
well so I like the balance of both I
like smart films that are fun Jodie
Foster here on the Rich Eisen show you
are also in a a sneaky underrated ok
sports movie because not many people
mentioned stealing home as a sports
movie ok yeah you know what I'm saying
there was baseball he's not partake in
the baseball I know that but when you
were on that set we've had Mark Harmon
here okay show and he talked about how
some of the scenes in it are reminiscent
of some sports films but it's obviously
more than just a sports movie were you
aware of the special nature and how it
could actually you know hit home and I
was a long time ago and I'm not sure was
the biggest hit that I've ever made but
yeah I leave it's a really a father-son
story in a lot of ways it's sort of a
coming of age story and I always look
for films that are emotional I mean I
think that that's why I go see movies I
go see movies to be moved
first and foremost right and then to be
challenged you know intellectually to be
challenged about meaningful things do
you have this favorite sports film
favorite sports movie that you've seen
Wow Stone movie but football comedy
given something you like that one loved
it
not to me because it really felt like
the game to me Pacino's speech in the
locker yeah yep and just great footage
and and you know how they handled the
camera and all right and and there were
some actual NFL players were in the drum
slowly you know that's a good one too
but my favorite it Hoosiers you ever see
that that that's the one that gets me
you know because every everyone every as
you mentioned father-son also Field of
Dreams is a father-son moment at the end
of that sort of thing and then your your
filmography if you don't mind me asking
a few questions about it on the set of
taxi driver you were like you are 12
years old 12 years old I know as any
time I've seen that it has blown me away
what was it like for you to be on the
set of taxi driver as he
twelve-year-old Jody well I've made a
lot of movies already so I probably had
made more movies than Robert De Niro and
Martin Scorsese at that point so I kind
of was coming there thinking well it'll
just be another movie it was really
life-changing for me I think was the
first time in my life that I really
realized that acting was more than just
saying a bunch of lines that somebody
else wrote and I thought for a second
like oh wow this is this is something
that maybe I could do when I grow up and
reading the script didn't I know
obviously you'd had a lot of credits I'd
already done a movie with Scorsese had
already done Alice doesn't live here
anymore where Scorsese and my mom took
me to everything I mean that was the
relationship that I had with my mom
she'd pick me up from school in my
little uniform and then we immediately
went to movies and sometimes we'd see a
double feature you know and we eat
dinner somewhere inside the movie
theater and come home and that was my
whole life growing up or we were serious
dramas and the 1970s is really the
Golden Age of American cinema so that's
the best time then be nice men to truly
unbelievable I mean a taxi driver even
today it is truly you know it's
difficult to tell people who might be
young to not know what they've heard
some of the lines and they don't even
know what movie it's from we have all
those movies at that time you know was a
sort of ohter spirit where we all four
for one ten-year period really believed
that directors were the point of making
films and and the studio's decided that
they would give them all the power
that's missing today yes absolutely 100%
I mean these you know things changed
movie business changes the good news is
if you're a performer you're an actor or
director if you're not working in
features you're working in television
maybe you're on my phone maybe you're on
YouTube I mean there are all sorts of
opportunities now that didn't exist
before for you to just do what you do
and and you know the medium be damned
and then Jodie Foster a couple more
minutes left Whizzer here Hotel Artemis
and theaters near you tonight where you
play the nurse in hotel Artemis with a
great cast you go to Yale all right
correct yes and I went to you well you
went to Yale okay and there I don't know
if you're aware but you going to Yale
was brought up on Game two of the NBA
finals no way yes because it the part
where the calves were really losing it
no it's not that
no no it's that Jeff Van Gundy who was
on the broadcast said he went to school
with you no way in a class do you sorry
Jeff don't remember yes yes
you weren't there memorable cuz the
reverses no that's great yeah yeah yeah
your phone did wasn't lighten up from
friends saying yeah I wish I had seen it
I wish I'd seen him I would have been
able to see his face and maybe you know
I think we could can we bring up a
picture of Jeff Van Gundy I don't know
such as stroll down memory lane here
with uh with Jodie Foster I'm putting
our crew on the spot and but I'm gonna
be watching tonight I don't know about
you okay not no no it is tonight yeah
you got game you've got game for tonight
you got game fine I know it's tonight
for us but I don't know for pre-recorded
or we're live or what one in the middle
is Jeff Van Gundy does that stir does
that ring a bell rings no well
whatsoever
I'm so sorry Jeff no class reunions at
all would be Jodie Foster and Jeff Van
Gundy okay I'm thrilled though that
that's that's thrilling news to me but
dave bautista is in hotel Artemus I know
yeah so I guess wrestling's a sport
right oh my gosh there's no doubt and
but he's he's one of those who have now
he's turned the page on that yeah I mean
he is he is he is amazing cruise he has
now turned the page where he's I think
he's more many people were more familiar
with him and what he's done Gardens the
galaxy and obviously what's going on
what was it like when you were first
time together it's a great relationship
in the movie hd and he plays them I sort
of we have this sort of mother-son love
story in the movie where you know where
I was picking on each other and saying
mean things to each other and and then
in the end it's you know we have that
sort of big heartfelt embrace where his
giant tattooed bicep is in my face did
you get many grief it'll uh he says I
gave him grief I don't remember getting
grief but apparently the first thing I
said to him which apparently I repeated
over and over again is you're not that
big I thought you'd be bigger you're not
that big he he is big jerks he's not
that's what he's listed I don't know if
it supports things he's not six to six
to which is tall if you've ever seen me
if you've ever seen me you know 60 was
tall to me I got a really look up to 62
but he's massive so here's what you're
saying is that WWE might be lying in its
guide is what you're saying yeah that's
what I'm saying we got a shot right now
of you on screen with him how much what
are you what are you listed out right
now in the Yale guide 5-3 okay yeah I
got my full on Tennessee I got my
fictitious in hotel Artemus a Jody I
really appreciate you coming on the show
thanks for hanging out here check out a
hotel Artemus again in theaters near you
tonight what an incredible cast sterling
K Brown was phenomenal yes Jeff Goldblum
it's always great seeing him Jenny slate
Zachary Quinto and Dave Bautista just to
name a few with Charley dad good to see
you Jody thanks yeah Jody foster here on
the Rich Eisen sure the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience